[Música]
la confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas de ecuador conaie llamó a
radicalizar la protesta contra el
gobierno de presidente guillermo lazo
tras la detención por parte de la
policía de su presidente la unida sisa
la detención de issam se produjo en la
madrugada del martes mientras transitaba
en un vehículo en la provincia andina de
cotopaxi ubicada en el centro del país
de acuerdo a la cuna ya el arresto
intervino grupos especiales de la
policía y el ejército del ecuador entre
los principales reclamos de los
indígenas está el alza del costo de la
vida especialmente de los precios de los
combustibles vamos a saludar entonces
nuestro primer invitado del día ls juan
paz y miño analista y doctor en historia
contemporánea director académico del
ecuador también de la asociación de
historiadores latinoamericanos y del
caribe profesor universitario gracias
profesora juan por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de francés de ecuatoria
preguntó cuál será el balance hasta
ahora de estos días protestas indígenas
en ecuador y que puede esperarse en este
llamado a la radicalización
gracias no es solo el movimiento
indígena el que se ha pronunciado y ha
decretado este paro indefinido de
actividades sino que se han unido
diversas organizaciones
laborales organizaciones barriales
populares estudiantes maestros los
sectores de profesionales como por
ejemplo unos médicos del sector público
tal manera que ha sido una convocatoria
muy amplia de hecho esta convocatoria ha
paralizado o semiparalizado 18 de las 24
provincias que tiene el ecuador y es
particularmente fuerte en la sierra
ecuatoriana en la amazonía y menos
fuerte en la costa ecuatoriana de tal
manera que es una movilización compleja
difícil
tensionante y tras la prisión del
presidente de la conaie leonidas iza la
conaie misma ha convocado a radicalizar
la protesta entonces hoy el segundo día
de esta paralización podemos ver qué
consecuencias tiene pero en efecto si es
que la represión ya llega al primer
dirigente de la conaie y el presidente
ha advertido que se pondrá en prisión a
todas las personas que han sido las
ideológicamente preparadoras de esta
jornada y que materialmente la ejecutan
y si es que eso se va a va a darse la
prisión de estas personas bueno se
agravan las tensiones sociales la
conflictividad en el ecuador es muy
fuerte debido al modelo de economía y de
sociedad que lleva adelante el gobierno
del presidente guillermo lasso que es
una continuidad a lo que se hizo durante
el gobierno de lenin moreno entre 2017 y
2021 y ahora juan lo que usted está
diciendo me lleva bien a mi segunda
pregunta digamos esta sería también una
radicalización por parte del presidente
guillermo lasso porque esta postura tan
radical no sé si pues se han sentado en
una mesa de diálogo a conversar al
gobierno y estos grupos que también
llenan las protestas como lo es el
colectivo indígena
entre otras cosas el colectivo indígena
las organizaciones indígenas y
campesinas pero además organizaciones de
trabajadores se quejan que durante
varias
oportunidades en que ellos han planteado
sus puntos de vista sobre la conducción
del gobierno no han sido escuchados esos
planteamientos y en cambio se escucha
rápidamente y se sigue a línea seguida
los planteamientos que hacen las élites
económicas y empresariales más ricas del
ecuador la conaie mismo publicó una
secuencia de reuniones que se han dado
con el gobierno y que sin embargo no han
merecido la respuesta que ellos
esperaban y por consiguiente dicen bueno
hoy estamos conversando de que no nos
quedan más que las calles por el hecho
de que el gobierno está destruyendo
nuestros planteamientos pero hay un
problema de fondo históricamente
hablando esto es que el modelo de
economía que sigue el gobierno que es un
modelo de economía abierta empresarial
neoliberal
se conjuga con los intereses sociales
como ya tenemos experiencia en américa
latina en las décadas finales del siglo
20 y con los gobiernos conservadores de
la actualidad ese es un modelo que
agrava las condiciones de vida y de
trabajo de la población eso ha ocurrido
en los últimos cinco años en el ecuador
cuando se revirtió un modelo de economía
social que se intentó seguir en los diez
años anteriores entonces hoy vivimos
esta época difícil complicada por el
hecho de que este modelo empresarial
neoliberal sin duda afecta las
condiciones de vida de trabajo y tensión
a la sociedad porque los sectores
populares se ven desprotegidos y se
desmantelan los bienes y servicios
públicos entre otras entre las
cuestiones como antes se había atendido
en su opinión profesional cuál sería
entonces lo que tendría que hacer
digamos más asertivamente el gobierno
del presidente guillermo lasso para
poder atender estos reclamos sociales de
los indígenas que como usted lo dijo y
pues no vienen del día de ayer o hace
unos días atrás
es difícil que en un gobierno con las
fuerzas que le apoyan y ante todo con
ese sector empresarial tan conservador y
reaccionario que tiene el ecuador en la
perspectiva de hegemonía hegemonizar la
vida económica del país digo es difícil
que cambie pero también puede comprender
y esto es lo que habría que hacer el
llamado al presidente también puede
comprender que aún siendo un gobierno de
derecha no tiene por qué descuidar una
serie de transformaciones y de
beneficios sociales como es fomentar la
educación pública la salud pública la
medicina pública la seguridad social que
para qué se las destruye si con ellos
incluso garantizan mejor sus propias
perspectivas de desarrollo
exactamente empresarial y capitalista
entonces creo que hay que hacer un
llamado al gobierno para que oriente
estos servicios públicos de beneficio
social no profundice la conflictividad
política y la conflictividad social y de
un ligero giro a su a su visión del
mundo que no puede seguir siendo pues
aquella del privilegio como la cepal ha
denominado a este tipo de economías que
se han implementado en américa latina y
que siguen solamente la cultura de una
élite si se puede dar algunos beneficios
sociales en medio de condiciones
difíciles profesor ya rápidamente
digamos si no se hace este cambio o esta
mesa de diálogo para escuchar a estas
comunidades por parte del gobierno del
presidente de las estas protestas
pudieran aumentar viendo el pasado
es previsible que si es que no se logran
cambios significativos en la sociedad y
se sigue alimentando un modelo
excluyente de los intereses sociales
populares campesinos indígenas de
trabajadores de clases medias más
amplios bueno la vida del país siga
conflictuando se y por consiguiente si
es que el diálogo las nuevas mesas la
posición del gobierno no hablan de las
condiciones es previsible que la
situación social pueda tensionarse cada
vez más como se ha advertido en otros
países que han seguido un camino
parecido al ecuatoriano